the way you get out of debt is you get
mad because personal finance is 80%
behavior it's only 20% head knowledge
people change their lives when they
finally say that's when people change
their lives you can wander into debt
darling you cannot wander out you have
to get pissed off about your status quo
I make too much to be this freaking
broke when you do you'll change your
life and you list your debts smallest to
largest regardless of the interest rate
you pay minimum payments on everything
but the little one and you attack the
little one with a vengeance because
personal finance is 80 percent behavior
it's only 20 percent ahead knowledge you
already know what to do but you need to
see the traction of winning that's why
the debt snowball works you pay off that
little one you're like yeah you proud
the next one you uh huh you pay off the
next one yeah but not time you pay off
the car you're standing the middle of
street screaming I'm tax free the
neighbors think you've lost your mind
and you don't care what the neighbors
think anymore
because that when you cared what the
neighbors thought that's what got you
into debt you no longer are trying to
impress others you're trying to change
your family tree and live a life of
dignity see this is how it works this is
why we use the debt snowball that's why
it's work it's why five million people
have now gone through Financial Peace
University because when you get in a
community of people around you that love
you enough to encourage you and
challenge your stupid behaviors and you
get teaching that you've never seen
before and you think differently you
start to behave differently and when you
start to behave differently you get a
different set of results Financial Peace
University is a nine week class it's
been taught in 50,000 churches to five
million people now any given time it's
in ten to fifteen thousand churches it
is right now so you can go and guess
what today today we're changing it this
is the first major change in Financial
Peace University in my goodness almost a
decade
we're adding so much stuff to Financial
Peace University free for you today that
it makes it to the point that if you
don't take this class now you're just
straight-up stupid you're just stupid if
you don't take this class now because as
of today you sign up for Financial Peace
University we're going to ship you the
kit to go to the class which we've
always done but now you get one year of
every dollar plus included that's $100
value shut up I just cut the price of
both of those things in half shut up
I mean seriously every dollar plus is
included for your Oh guess what else is
included for a year a year you get full
access to all the videos and all the
lessons and everything at Financial
Peace University online as well so you
can follow along online you can follow
up online you can listen to audio online
you can watch the videos online you can
follow your every dollar plus for a year
both of those are for a year and then
you get your butt into a class too and
take your kit and try don't over find a
local church and get plugged in it'll
change your life I just cut the price by
phone Financial Peace University
effectively I didn't cut the price but I
doubled tripled I tripled the value just
then our Financial Peace University team
has been working with the every dollar
team and working with Financial Peace
University online team and we figured
out that you need these three things
together to ensure your transformation
and we're about causing you to win baby
and it's time you got up off your butt
and started winning if you've been
waiting
well you waited just long enough because
now it's unbelievably a bargain every
dollar plus for a year online Financial
Peace University for a year and the
class and the class kit so you get your
kit shipped to you oh did I mention free
shipping I forgot to mention that free
shipping too this is unbelievable this
is the first major change in this
product line in quite a while and I got
to tell you it is the best change we've
ever made to it in the history of the
product we went from VHS to DVD we went
from 13 legends to nine
since we've reshot the thing a couple
times we've moved around we've changed
the product over the last 15 or 20 years
a couple times but now you've got the
world's best budgeting tool tied to your
bank for free included for a year you've
got full online accessibility for all
your mobile devices it works beautifully
the thing is our team is put together in
a way that is just so elegant it is so
easy to use so the full online
experience and the full class experience
at a local church don't leave that out
that's where the magic happens baby so
you put it all in there together we just
tripled the value just now you just
heard it just now it just now happened
on Financial Peace University but it's
up to you are you are you are you ready
to have no payments are you ready to
increase your generosity are you ready
to join the millionaire club you've got
to do something different to get
something different you know that it's
your time baby right now hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]